We have a voicemail number. That number is
2192. David P here is a caller asking Why
didn't I do heavy promotion of the Lex Freedman
interview that I did? Take a listen. David,
it's Alan from Jersey. I'm online and I did
an interview with Lex Freedman, the world
famous Lex Freedman of the Lex Freedman podcast.
I can't believe when did this happen? How did this
happen? Where did this come from? Gave you such
a big, you know, earth shattering event of this.
You should have been promoting this, David. You
should have told us you're scheduling it. And then
after it was scheduled, you should have said this
is when it's going to happen and then say this and
then say it just happened and then say it just
happened yesterday and then say it happened two
days ago. Let's say Lex told me it's going to take
three or four more days before it's posted. David,
why didn't you give us every single update of
every single step in the process of you doing
like Scream And people would want to know that
type of information, but instead you gave us
no warning. Okay, so here's the deal. Many of
you know that I hesitate to pre promote things,
especially things beyond my control, because
sadly, they often get canceled or postponed. They
never happen. And then people end up asking what
happened. And in fact, the Lex Freedman interview
was originally scheduled for a couple of months
ago and I did pre promote it on a couple of live
streams and then it did get canceled at the very
last minute. And then I had nothing. I was there.
I was sitting there holding my hat, as people
say. So this time around when it got rescheduled,
I just didn't say a word about it in case
it got canceled again. And unfortunately,
this happens with interviews we do on our show.
Then they get canceled. Perfect example is today's
Barbara Lee interview that we finally did and
aired today with you. It was postponed five times.
And so imagine if I had promoted right after the
Adam Schiff interview. Hey, And tomorrow, we've
got Barbara Lee coming up, who's also running
for that same Dianne Feinstein Senate seat.
And then I'm left holding my hat and we have no
interview and then it's not clear what happened.
So that's why I am now kind of cautious about
promoting things that I don't totally control
because they so often end up postponed. All right.
That's why. But now the Lex Freedman interview is
out. Check it out. I posted it to my Twitter. I
posted it to my blue sky. Blue sky. By the way,
are you on blue sky? Please follow me on blue
sky. I think it's actually a fantastic platform.
It is invite only right now, but the invites are
going out very strongly. Follow me on Blue Sky.
It's on Lex's YouTube channel. It's everywhere.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Should the US get rid of the debt ceiling? Is
that a possible way to get beyond this periodic
predictable debt ceiling situation? We can discuss
that on the bonus show. What did the California
Panel on Reparations say about what should
be done with regard to reparations? We will
discuss. And lastly, the Biden administration
has some interesting new plans for requiring
airlines to pay stranded passengers, cover meals,
cover hotels in a much more powerful way than is
required right now. Does this make sense? Is it
overregulation? Is it a nanny state or is it just
consumer protection? All of those stories and more
on today's bonus show. Sign up at join Pacman dot
com. If you don't have the pleasure of the bonus
show, then we'll see you back here tomorrow.